in about two hours from now president
Trump will be holding a homecoming rally
in the crucial battleground state of
Florida his campaign says it's in part
to celebrate his official move from New
York City to the Sunshine State
Mike Bloomberg steam is warning
Democrats that Trump is well positioned
to win reelection Mike is getting in
this race because he thinks that Donald
Trump is an existential crisis and he
thinks he's on a path to victory right
now Donald Trump is winning and is very
tough for people who don't live in New
York or California to understand that
but that is what's happening meanwhile a
new report from Politico claims former
President Obama is being privately
critical of former former Vice President
Joe Biden Obama reportedly telling an
unnamed 2020 candidate that Biden quote
really doesn't have it when it comes to
establishing a bond or rapport with the
electorate in Iowa what do you think of
that Jesse I mean does it take a brain
surgeon to figure that out
I've been saying that for a whole year
Biden doesn't have it we don't need a
poll to tell me Biden doesn't have it
just look at him on television there's
no Biden base there's no Biden mantra
there's no Biden slogan there's no Biden
movement there's nothing so I don't know
why people have to look at these polls
and worry about Joe Biden beating Donald
Trump it's never gonna happen and even
the guy that picked them to be VP and
spent eight years with them knows it's
never gonna happen so let's just forget
about Joe Biden he's overrated
the only person more overrated than
Biden is Bloomberg so what if he has
money he's not gonna win one single
state all the advertising that he's
going to drop on Trump's gonna backfire
it's gonna over saturate all the markets
Trump's getting attacked by a short
billionaire from New York City it's
going to strengthen the Trump yeah I'm
telling you 30 years from now they're
gonna Drudge up this tape and you are
gonna be totally alright so Dana what
you know it's interesting you hear that
you know
Bloomberg's campaign manager saying Oh
Donald Trump is winning but I mean we
would expect that the incumbent would
have some kind of statistical advantage
on the other
and if you look at the RealClearPolitics
average Biden is beating Trump by 10
yeah and not only that Warren's beating
him by six Sanders by seven well though
it could be true in the popular vote
sense right but it's not true in the
battlegrounds and we saw the numbers
from Wisconsin last week in the
Marquette poll that was obviously quite
a that was a good good boost for the
Trump campaign but Florida is where
President elections presidential
elections are decided and the president
has just moved his residency from New
York to Florida Bloomberg has a solid
base of support
more recently in Virginia because of all
the money he plowed into there to help
get Democrats elected mostly on gun
issues but sometimes on climate change
legislature the thing about President
Trump Vice President Biden and President
Obama I'm sorry Trump Bloomberg and
Obama they all agree on one thing that
Biden is not going to be the nominee and
that he can't beat Trump and wait a
second you think that that's really what
Obama said I doubt it you see I think
that all of the signals are that there
are worries from Obama that Biden will
not be able to win the presidency even
if he gets the nomination remember going
back to President Obama saying you don't
have to do this Joe you don't have a big
groundswell of support like if Biden was
running away with this thing we would
all know it it would be obvious now his
poll numbers are do remain high but when
it comes to those early States I don't
think he's there obviously he's even
admitted that and they're not being
they're not able to raise the money so
if you can't do that there's just no
groundswell of support now is there a
point where Biden can say I'm gonna
consolidate all of these different
factions and together together for me I
think the only way for him to do that
right now is if President Obama were to
come out and say Biden is the guy so all
of you need to get in line but it
doesn't look like Biden's Obama's gonna
do that no by the way so here take a
look at Pete Buda Jake here's he here he
is saying that he he's not the guy that
Obama was talking to for this you know
anonymous quote I'm not and what I will
say is that you know our message is
resonating here I think because Iowans
are looking for bold future oriented
vision and a willingness and readiness
to do that
in a way that unifies not divides all
right so Greg I wanted to ask you to
counter my cynicism but the president is
going down to Florida tonight yeah and
as you heard me say he's advertising
this as a homecoming right because he's
moved from New York to Florida as they
said a critical state but I'm thinking
to myself to things Gregory to one I'm
thinking hey you don't have to pay
income taxes in Florida right yeah maybe
that's why he's mine yeah okay and then
the second thing I'm thinking is he gets
to go home early for Thanksgiving while
I'm working there you go here was to do
it's funny though here's the big problem
you followed up Budaj edge with the talk
about a rally and that is a huge issue
the Dems are suffering from fun Envy you
look at these you look at the Democratic
faces you got Biden you got Bernie you
got bloomie it's like the Golden Girls
without the sex appeal right and then
you got Buddha Jess who's boring and as
big as all hell it's like the den when
you compare the Dems to the rally it's
like the DMV versus Delta house I mean
there's a certain group of people that
are having the time of their lives and
then you got a bunch of misery bunch of
like people that are just sad all the
time
poor Joe I feel bad for Joe he he's like
think he's like the kid waiting for his
brother to pick him up for school and
it's like seven o'clock they just forgot
if Obama were good a good friend he
would pull Joe aside and say look Joe
you got to move on she's not into you
okay
you keep hanging out in front of her
house she keep buying her flowers but
she's dating somebody else
the guy's name is trump sorry but I eat
but and then you saw Blue Mesa so how
blue he's ad had the energy of a nap did
you see that
let's get it on he's got to it Oh might
know it let's go to sleep what's the
Delta house that you're talking about Oh
a delta house was Animal House oh okay I
thought there was like a delta lounge
that I didn't know
exactly TV show called Delta house that
was a spinoff of Animal House gotcha by
the way for all the bad things that you
say about Biden he continues to lead you
know
well because it's actually kind of a
good person oh okay well I mean because
everyone else is so what all right so
let's take a look here at Robert De Niro
why DeNiro talking about Michael
Bloomberg Emily you react on the other
side I like Bloomberg he's a he's an
adult he's a grown-up yeah we just have
to get past this get over the hump into
calm waters and so to me Bloomberg might
be the one Wow so here I mean people
usually say he's far left but here he is
now apparently endorsing Bloomberg well
I think that's more indicative of the
Los Angeles New York coastal approach to
a lot of these campaigning which ignores
the majority of the country I think
what's interesting about Bloomberg is
that for all of the measured success
that people cite with him it's never
himself that he's selling he was never
the commodity he was always bankrolling
either someone else you know all the
seats that he's flipped and all the
issues that he's really made a
difference with yes that was his money
but it wasn't him so I think we've yet
to hear exactly how his message will be
I'm the one that's going to save the
Democrats and then secondly whether that
will even work I also think that Biden
came out with a measure of hubris that
no one expected and I think that he
thought automatically he would have
Obama support and everyone's support
because of that he never made the
pilgrimage and I think Obama always was
like three times not a term so he's
probably learning really late in the
game that this was a likely so I was
hearing today if Democrats saying oh you
know Bloomberg supported a lot of
Republicans and used to talk about Rudy
Giuliani is one of his favorites and he
gave money to Orrin Hatch and Pett to
Democrats who are mad at him that's what
I'm saying yeah yeah the Democrats are
saying hey wait a second you're running
for the Democratic nomination but
Bloomie's not really running he's
running ads for the Democratic Party to
crush Trump he's not reload this is back
to your conspiracy it's not a conspiracy
it's a theory and I have never been
wrong
my entire life never been wrong can I
call your wife
Conan's a boy well know that that'll be
discussed in a later segment Emily we
don't know if the dog is a boy or a girl
it's the worst gender reveal ever yeah